we run a slot room and it's all senior
citizens and then one of them turns
around Haggard old man what's his name
Clyde Clyde okay he turns around to you
and he's like
you know I'm bisexual in college
I'm I'm married 40 years about how to
[__] the [__] out of a guy like you all
right Clyde thank you man I appreciate
it you got a great ass champ okay thank
you man
God and then you turn around to walk
away and he smacks it he's like well my
hand got free
and then when there's an old person just
crying at the machine
my stipend has run out that's too bad
you're gonna have to my retirement
you're gonna have to get off the chair
we have people waiting there's there's
people in the lobby so we're gonna need
you to bounce slides here we got a
special little things
yeah yeah form a conspiracy Clyde wins
because Cody wants to have sex with him